Everything you're about to see
was performed either
by professionals or with
the support of professionals.
If you don't have that support,
do not try this.
I got an email from
Jack at UKPW,
which is a small indie wrestling
promotion in the South East,
asking if I want to do a cameo spot
at one of their shows.
I have no pain tolerance.
I have no experience.
The show's tomorrow,
so what are we gonna do?
Right, we're gonna have some fun, Tom.
So what's gonna happen is
we're gonna take you through
some of the most fundamental,
fundamental points of
professional wrestling.
You're gonna learn some breakfalls.
You're gonna learn a little bit of tumbling.
You're gonna learn a little bit extra.
I'm not gonna tell you right now.
You're then gonna use what
you've learned in our show tomorrow.
Alright. (nervous chuckle)
Where do we start?
I mean, in the ring, I guess.
Yep, let's get going!
Alright. Can't believe
you slapped your thighs.
(laughs)
Hello.
Hello, gentlemen.
Mike.
It's very nice to see you.
It's nice to see you too, Jack.
Hello, good sir.
How are we?
(laughs) Nervous, I'll be honest.
I have never done anything like this.
Well, you're lucky. I've spent
20 years doing stuff like this, so.
Right, okay.
I have trained people from
the very basics all the way up to
full-time contracted wrestlers
with big companies.
So, you're in about as good
a hands as they can be in.
I mean, my first problem is gonna be
getting through the ropes into the ring,
which is also a thing
I've never done before, so...
Alright, that's—
You're more than welcome.
Thank you.
Where do we start?
First things first.
A wrestler's best hold
is conditioning.
So, if you are
not in ring shape, then...
you're gonna last all of about
two minutes before you fall over
and have a minor seizure.
'Kay.
So, great to start, simple squats.
Okay?
The form I'm looking for is
arse all the way to the floor,
hands down, scoop the floor,
all the way back up.
Okay.
We'll start light with 100.
Seriously?
That— That's light.
Okay.
I normally do about 200 a day.
(sighs)
Okay.
We'll start light, okay?
(chuckles)
So just...
♪ (driving hard rock)
Off we go.
Alright.
And down. Scoop.
Let's go.
Drop.
Good.
Don't have the upper arm
strength I used to!
Next one we'll go onto is shuffles.
Go!
That's it.
Drop!
Good.
That's it, remember— Drop.
And rest.
We're gonna start with just
some tumbles and some rolls,
just to get your body
used to sort of moving,
and then we're gonna get
into breakfalls,
because protecting yourself
is paramount.
Something like this.
That was smooth.
This won't be!
(groan) Yeah, just hit my head there.
Word to the wise.
Yeah?
You need your head.
So let's—
Yeah, I do. Let's not do that.
Better. Much better.
Gonna switch it.
Alright.
Ooh, that was a bad one.
(sigh) Try that again.
Better. Good.
(music ends)
Ooh, that hurts.
Traditional back breakfall
will look like this:
Bloody hell!
...Okay!
But obviously,
expecting you to just do that
right off the bat...
Yeah no, I don't even know—
That looked to me
like a just complete...
plant on your back.
That felt like it...
It— It feels like it too.
Okay!
Take it from me, but...
...by lifting my legs...
Yeah.
...and planting my arms out.
I'm able to distribute the weight
— or the impact, excuse me —
across all of the major
muscles in my back.
Rather than sort of land awkwardly
on joints and things like that.
Agh, this is gonna suck. Alright.
So, what we'll do,
we'll just start
from a low squatting position.
Yep.
Push your hips out.
Throw your arms out.
Yeah.
Palms down.
This is very important.
Because if you go that way,
you have all these small,
wonderful joints in your fingers.
Yeah, okay.
Which, perfect for breaking.
So, we're just gonna
push our hips out...
(loud slam)
...and just drive our hands
into the floor.
(chuckles) Alright.
Sure, okay!
Start down low.
So...
Start down low, about here.
Mhm.
So I'm gonna start here.
Yep.
I'm gonna throw these out
with my palms back.
Yep.
And I'm just gonna whack the floor.
Essentially, yeah.
But make sure
you lift your hips as well.
Lift my hips.
Keep my head up as well, presumably.
Yes, absolutely.
It's a lot to remember.
Okay.
(exhales)
Not bad.
Didn't keep my hip—
That hit there first.
Well, that's not the worst I've seen.
(chuckles)
It's a good place to start. And again.
No. That was worse,
'cause I felt that.
You want to land all together.
Yeah.
If you're here... (pats twice)
...that means
something's gone wrong.
(grunt) No.
(grunt) No. And that was
my lower back as well.
'Kay, we're gonna start
from the top. Okay?
You'll realise that
that sucks as much as that.
There's no real...
You're landing on the floor.
Regardless of height...
...you're landing on the floor.
Yep.
(pained growl)
Good.
(sharp moan)
Just remember, arms high,
swing 'em across.
Gah!
(grunt)
Agh!
Good.
I mean, I yelled on it,
but I don't think I needed to.
No.
Still sucked!
Oh, it's the least pleasant thing that
you're gonna be going through today.
Okay.
There's not many more
pleasant things, but...
That's probably the least...
I wasn't expecting anything pleasant.
Let's be clear.
Obviously travelling backwards
is one thing.
But travelling forwards...
Yeah, okay.
A lot of people tend to be...
...more afraid of this, because they can see
the floor coming up to meet them.
But...
Huh.
I would've thought
it was the other way around.
'Cause you can see what's coming,
and you can brace for it.
As opposed to...
"The floor's somewhere.
I gotta time it."
Keep your hips straight.
Yeah.
And just...
Oh!
I'm falling from my knees.
I'm not falling from my hips.
Nope. And...
Okay.
Put those arms... in.
Arms in like this.
Almost like a triangle.
Yep. Alright.
There you go.
That I can do.
Easy.
That's fine.
I can do that. (chuckles)
Can I do that?
It felt like I could do that.
You did.
Okay! That...
There you go.
That's a standard pratfall—
(crew giggling)
I can hear you laughing!
Great shot.
That's a standard pratfall.
I can do that. That's fine. Yeah, okay.
However, you're now gonna ask me
to do it from this height, aren't you?
Of course.
Yeah.
So, just bringing your legs up,
and should land something like this.
Awwh!
(chuckles) Okay.
Now, be careful.
Yeah. I'm gonna want to
drop my knees first.
You don't want to drop to your knees.
I know.
And you certainly don't
want to drop...
...anywhere in the middle.
Okay.
I know what I need to do.
My brain just refuses to do it.
That's because you have
this amazing thing
called common sense.
Wrestlers somehow
seem to lose that
just before they take up wrestling.
Alright. How hard can it be?
I just need to land
here and here first.
(grunt) No, that was bad.
That was a jump forward.
That was.
That was everything you said not to do.
That was everything
you said not to do.
I had my hands out first.
There was I thinking this side
was gonna be easier(!) Alright.
So it's just: feet go back.
Yep.
Lean forward, feet go back.
No, I— (angry moan)
(lolls tongue)
Start with that. Start here.
Nope, you're right.
That really sucks.
Yeah.
'Cause...
'Cause I landed with exactly
what I shouldn't do.
Yeah. You want to avoid that.
Mmhm. Yep. Yep.
'Cause you might need that.
This is—
Mmph. Yeah, it hurts.
Just take a second to breathe.
Yep!
I highly recommend breathing
at this point!
That... That is the first time...
...the first time that I've had
a crotch injury on this channel.
That's...
Mm. That takes...
Takes about ten seconds
to kick in, doesn't it?
That's...
Okay. Yeah.
Give it another ten seconds.
It's a completely different
sort of pain.
It's a really good motivation,
that is!
It's a really good motivation
not to screw it up.
♪ (driving hard rock)
Nngh-aha!
(grunt) Nope.
(grunt) Oh, that's better!
Gah! My knees.
What the hell was going on
with my knees there?
If you shoot down like that,
that pulls you on
this part of your forearm,
whereas if you turn it down,
this big forearm muscle here.
Okay.
The idea being that you want to
land on muscles, rather than joints.
Or... other parts.
Bones.
Yeah. Yeah.
Again, breakable things.
Better.
Unfortunately, Tom,
in this game...
Yeah. Yeah.
...it just hurts.
(music ends)
(growls)
Good.
Mmph.
Anything fall off?
No, not this time.
How're you feeling?
(sharp breath)
I'll live.
Good.
We're gonna get into
some grappling now.
Right.
When you see a lot of wrestlers,
they'll probably start engaging by...
...hooking behind the head
with the left arm.
Yeah.
Here...
...and over the right arm there.
Right.
Right at the forearm.
Not the elbow, the forearm.
Wait, elbow or forearm?
You're fine there,
but I'm using just my right hand.
Okay.
But not too far—
No, I mean on you.
Oh, on me, at the elbow.
At the elbow, okay.
That's why it's called collar-and-elbow.
Collar-and-elbow.
Alright.
Here we go. From here...
(bleep)
Yeah, okay.
I'm a ragdoll at that point.
I have no idea how to even
start defending against that.
To get into the collar-and-elbow,
we're gonna take a
left step forward,
shoot our left arm,
rather than around,
it's just gonna be straight,
and the right's gonna come over
at the same time.
Okay.
It should go...
I missed, but...
That's okay.
'Kay.
If you're just relying on just your arm,
pulling my head in...
Nothing's gonna happen.
If you use your whole body...
Yep.
...then you stand a much better
chance at pulling me.
Alright, alright, so...
Like that, yep.
And then it's gonna be...
Pull and step.
Ah, good.
Okay, link your hands.
Ah (bleep), yeah.
That's fine.
Yeah, okay.
Get that leg back.
Okay.
Get me a little higher up,
on your chest.
(stammers)
Get our left leg back.
Turn in to me and lead me.
Alright, yeah.
There you go, good.
That's a good headlock.
Okay.
Now I don't necessarily have to tell you
what's coming after this.
Just... react as you would.
Okay.
D'aah!
I think I would—
I think the real—
The more realistic thing would be
to wrestle my foot behind—
I don't know why I flailed around
with this right hand there.
Well, it's a natural thing
for people to do.
Yeah, okay.
But...
...if it was me...
Yeah.
...and you grab my arm,
maybe tuck that under your...
Maybe shoulder-bar me.
Yeah, okay.
I mean, the first thing I would do
is try to pick you up.
Yeah. And I would immediately
jump back out, 'cause...
Well yeah, you have to think.
What would...
What would I look for here?
There's your arm there,
not near the leg.
Hey!
Sorry. I breakfalled that!
It's almost like I taught you
to protect yourself.
And that's exactly what you did.
(laughs)
Should we drill you into the mat?
That's gonna suck...!
As we go up...
Yep.
...your... right arm is gonna...
(groans)
...press off my stomach.
Off your stomach here. Okay.
Yeah.
So, see if you keep
your left elbow in tighter.
Yeah. Yeah.
'Kay?
Oh, bit further over my back.
There. Okay.
Okay.
So, and just post your legs together.
Agh, yep.
And over you go.
Ohh! I didn't breakfall that!
You didn't.
(pained shout)
(grunt)
Now...
You weren't a million miles away
from where you needed to be.
Mhm.
This time...
...I want you to plant your feet...
...and push your hips
up off the floor.
Post off my stomach.
Post off stomach.
Post off there.
Legs together.
Now, wait. First off,
you're gonna go that way.
Yeah, thank—
We can run this slowly.
I mean, we can.
Yeah, I—
Feel free to show off on that
as much as you want.
Wah!
(strangled yell)
Okay, great, yeah.
(growls deeply)
There you go.
That yell... was not...
me actually being in pain.
Thank you. I feel like
I breakfalled that.
I don't know if I did.
It felt like I did.
So now, we're just gonna
put some chili sauce on it.
Right, okay.
And if this goes well...
Uh-huh.
...hopefully you'll never have to
get body slammed ever again.
Other than presumably once,
in the ring, tomorrow.
I couldn't say either way.
Uh-huh.
It'll just be a little faster,
theoretically.
Okay.
Alright, lovely boy. Here we go.
Alright.
(pained groan)
(wail)
(angry wail)
(groan)
It's a good thing.
Even with a breakfall,
that... really hurt!
(grunt)
Okay...!
It is a good thing.
Did I breakfall it?
You landed completely correctly.
(wheezes)
That sucks!
Mmmph!
I think the most miraculous thing is
I managed to not swear during that.
That... hurt like hell
in the moment.
It really, like, that sucked!
But...
...it's now like five minutes later.
And...
Like, yeah, there's a bit of an ache,
got a bit of a headache.
But I'm not, like, in trouble.
And that's a testament to Mike
and training and how he did that.
That was a fall that sucked,
and it's winded me.
But I'm... I'm okay.
And that's a new experience.
Tomorrow, there's gonna be
a crowd watching, and...
Like, that'll help.
Like, performance will help.
I just hope it doesn't distract.
'Cause... what I don't
wanna happen is being—
I don't wanna be carried off
on a stretcher, you know?
I've never had a sponsor
like this before.
They're not asking you
to buy anything.
They're asking if you want
to help change the world.
80,000 Hours is a nonprofit,
and they help people find a
fulfilling career that also does good.
Based on ten years of research
with academics from Oxford University,
they want to help you find a job that
makes a positive difference in the world,
helps solve the biggest problems
facing humanity,
and also gives you job satisfaction.
So they've asked me
to ask you
if that's something
you'd be interested in.
They have a website with their research,
a podcast, a newsletter.
They also have a job board
with hundreds of open listings that,
based on their research,
they believe are the best ways
to make the world better
for now and the future.
And all their advice and research,
everything they do, is free forever.
So if you are not sure what you
should do with yourself, with your job,
with the 80,000 hours you have
in an average working life,
then there's a link in the description
and a card on the screen.
They will send you their
in-depth career guide.
So, with the very best of luck
for your future,
back to the show!
♪ (uptempo rock music)
(music ends)
So first of all, Tom,
how are you feeling?
I ache.
Mike was very, very good.
Like, lot of breakfalling.
I took a body slam.
It hurt like hell.
But I'm here. So it's—
I'm doing okay.
What's the plan for today?
So, what the plan is, is you're gonna
be introduced to open the show.
You're gonna be the
special guest host.
You're gonna come out,
give a bit of dialogue, "Hello, I'm Tom."
"Welcome to the show.
It's gonna be a great show."
Eventually, you're gonna be interrupted
by the main event bad guy.
(chuckles)
He's called Ashmore.
He's big, muscley, bald, beard,
lots of tattoos, very intimidating.
And he's annoyed that you're
taking away his main event spotlight.
He's in the main event.
He should be praised by everybody.
So yeah, he's annoyed,
he's gonna tell you that.
But he's gonna offer out
a hand shake.
"As long as you don't
get in my way, we're cool."
You're gonna reluctantly,
more out of fear than anything,
accept the hand shake.
"Yeah, cool."
Seems normal, everything's fine.
You're gonna turn away,
as if you're walking away,
everything's finished,
he's gonna pull you back in.
Get you in the body slam position,
slam you to the floor.
Right.
And that's gonna obviously hurt.
We're gonna sell that it hurts.
You won't have to!
You didn't see that yesterday.
There was ten, fifteen seconds
of me just, on the floor,
just winded, writhing in pain.
That was not acting.
We won't have to worry about that.
Great, it's gonna look good then.
I can definitely sell this.
Then at the end of the show,
Roth and Ashmore
are gonna have their match.
Towards the end of the match,
the referee is gonna go down.
So the bad guy thinks,
"Ooh, I can cheat now!
'Cause I'm not gonna
get disqualified."
Goes underneath the ring,
gets a steel chair.
He's gonna taunt him, conveniently
with his back towards the entranceway.
He's gonna start stalking Roth.
As he lifts the chair over his head,
you're gonna appear from the entranceway,
You're gonna sprint out,
get onto the apron,
and steal the chair
out of Ashmore's hands.
You're then gonna
get down from the ring.
Ashmore's gonna be annoyed,
look at you, as he turns back around,
Roth clats him with something,
and Roth wins, he-hey!
Okay.
Are you worried that you're pulling back
the curtain a bit too much here?
'Cause when I was
growing up, it was—
There were rumours about,
it might be scripted, but you know,
as a kid, you watch it like,
"Ah, this is incredible."
Are you worried that we are...
giving too much away?
I don't think we're giving
too much away, because...
Like you said, back in the olden days
of wrestling, like '80s and '90s,
it was very closed-circuit,
and because of that,
it limited what the artform could be.
But now because
we're embracing what it is,
we know that it's not only
a sport and it hurts,
but it's also the
performance aspect of it.
It allows wrestling to be
so much more.
You could have a really
comedic-style match from Japan.
You could have a very
acrobatic-style match from Mexico.
It's allowed it to grow, and the audience
have so much more to enjoy now.
I wanna be able to
rehearse this, obviously.
But I also wanna find
a balance between
knowing what's gonna happen
and not completely wearing myself out.
So what's the plan in the next
couple hours before the show begins?
Well conveniently,
I think Ashmore has just arrived.
So we can start
going through your segment.
Alright.
Let's go!
Tom, let me introduce you to the man
you're gonna be working with.
This is Ashmore.
Hey.
Hello.
Nice to meet you. How you doing?
Nice to meet you.
This is the man that's gonna be walking you
through the beginning of the show.
And if both of you are ready,
we can start going through the beats
and get it all sorted.
Let's do it. Alright.
Yeah, let's go, let's go.
You've got the hand shake,
blah-blah-blah.
You walk away.
We do the pause,
like the cinematic pause.
I would say
if you don't look at me,
you can sort of look surprised
and be like that,
and I can look at the crowd,
and then if I give a little yank,
you come in at your own pace.
Then here, if you pop
your hand on my leg there.
Leg there rather than stomach.
Yeah, yeah.
It's either or,
but just for preference.
Then you'll be up.
Yep.
Then it's...
...boom.
Hands were the wrong way up
for the breakfall, but other than that.
That was perfect alignment.
Yeah.
Hands were the wrong way up.
I need to make sure they're down.
But other than that...
Flat landing, yeah.
I'm glad we had the crash mat there.
This is a bouncier ring than yesterday!
So I'm gonna be here,
bosh, bosh.
And if I'm here,
ready to smack him,
that's when you come up.
No, you don't!
Yeah, cool.
(crew laughing)
♪ (bluesy rock music)
Greetings, grapple fans!
(crowd cheering)
Bit nervous.
You're getting the hang of this.
But before we continue,
it gives me great privilege,
and it's a great honour
to introduce our special guest,
Tom Scott!
(crowd cheering)
Ladies and gentlemen,
boys and girls, everyone here,
welcome to
United Kingdom Pro Wrestling!
This has been a privilege
for me and my team.
We have spent the last few hours,
the last couple of days,
backstage watching
these athletes prepare.
Watching them get ready,
watching them go through
all the training
that they have to do.
And let me tell you,
you have a treat in store tonight.
Prepare to be amazed.
Prepare to be surprised.
Prepare—
♪ (hip-hop music)
(crowd booing)
Ashmore, this is not your time.
(music fades)
Now, pardon the interruption.
But I was out the back,
and I couldn't help...
...but listen to this guy
introduce wrestling.
Now, I didn't break my back
in this ring for ten years...
...for some YouTuber to come here
and introduce me!
But, that being said,
I do appreciate the effort
that you've given today
to stand in this ring.
It takes guts.
It takes cajones!
And I...
I just wanna say,
you stay out of my way today.
I've got a big championship match
in the main event.
You stay out of my way today,
and it'll all be gravy.
We'll be good, okay?
So here I am,
as a man to another man.
(crowd muttering)
(crowd clamouring "No")
(pained shout)
(crowd booing)
YouTube, baby!
(wolf howling)
♪ (dramatic hip-hop music)
(crowd clamouring)
(music fades offscreen)
(hoarse whisper) Well, I can breathe.
That ring is a lot more forgiving
than the one I trained in.
What's going through my head?
Nearly the ring!
(wheezes)
It's fine. I don't know how I landed it.
I feel like I landed
one hand wrong there.
But, ultimately,
I got down safely. I'm fine.
Got a bit of a headache,
got a bit shocked there, but...
Yeah, I'm fine.
I think I've gone out without any broken bones
and without any concussions, so...
Alright.
(slow-mo groan)
(slow-mo shout)
(softly) I got the hands wrong!
I landed— Okay, yeah—
The timing was great.
The fall was great.
Nearly there.
Your acting's great.
Like, I—
To me, I was genuinely worried
when you came off.
Your face just then, in slow motion,
you look properly in pain.
So you sold that really well.
I sold it. To be fair, I'm unhurt.
I'm gonna beat myself up about
the one thing I forgot to do.
But, the landing, timing,
it's not professional.
But it's good enough for someone
who's had a few hours' training.
I'll take that. I'll take that.
♪ (heavy metal music)
(metal shutters crash)
(crowd wincing)
So, I'm going out there
in a minute.
I've gotta pretend to be injured,
and I've gotta steal a chair.
And that's it.
Just words and timing.
I'm not gonna get thrown around.
♪ (electric guitar drone)
So I just have to not screw up
the bit of acting.
♪ (heavy metal music)
(crowd clamouring)
(music finishes)
No!
(crowd cheering)
You!
Ashmore!
This is not your chair!
This is not your time!
And this is not your match!
You're ruining my plan!
Ref!
(group in unison) One!
Two!
Three!
(bell dinging)
(crowd cheering)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]